this video contains spoilers for
multiverse madness yep you heard that
right oh and it also includes spoilers
for a quiet place but uh figure you care
less about that one
hello internet
welcome to film theory the show that's
probably best described as the loud
place usually also the obnoxious place
certainly the nerdy place and also
hopefully the place you want to
subscribe ah a quiet place one of two
horror movies in which we watch jim from
the office get ripped apart in front of
our eyes i guess there's just something
about his face that screams put me
through a paper shredder just saying he
might be the new mr fantastic but there
is nothing fantastic about his track
record surviving on the big screen
anyway seeing him in multiverse of
madness got me revisiting his past works
and i gotta say a quiet place one still
a banger when this thing came out in
2018 it was game changing not only did
it provide huge representation for deaf
actors but in a pop culture landscape
where everything is constantly screaming
in your face for attention the movie's
silent ad campaign stood out as
completely unique the film introduces us
to a race of aliens known as the death
angels yeah that is their official name
based on the news clippings that are
shown in the film but these aren't your
garden variety xenomorphs my friends
these are apex predators that hunt
purely by sound the opening minutes make
it immediately clear just how deadly
these things are when we watch little
bow find himself a loud toy and get
absolutely wrecked
come to think of it these guys should
probably team up with the invisible
creatures from bird box and the weeping
angels from doctor who they'd be like an
unbeatable sensory legion of doom as a
result of their sensitivity to sound the
world has become as the title says a
quiet place in order to survive people
walk on sand to muffle the sound of
their footsteps they use sign language
to talk and they play board games using
fabric pieces because plastic pieces
would be too darn loud hold up is that
are they playing monopoly if that is the
entertainment that they have available i
don't know i might be sacrificing myself
to the death angels the survivors have
set up security systems that use
fireworks as distraction mechanisms and
one of the few bits of relief that we
and the characters get from the
oppressive silence is when they go and
visit a waterfall that allows them to
safely shout and you see it's all of
these details that make the world of
this movie so darn good the world feels
really thought out lived in like the
people who've lasted this long have
truly done their homework in order to
survive and then part two came out and
threw most of that away but you know
sequel anyway i think at this point
we've all seen at least one how to
survive a quiet place video and the
survival tips tend to amount to
something like live near the waterfall
so the sound of the water covers you
great thanks a lot captain obvious i
want to go deeper i don't want preschool
survival tactics i want post grad stuff
i want to scientifically pinpoint the
exact decibel ranges that'll keep me
alive is stepping on an errant leaf and
instant death
is going shoeless on a path of sand
really necessary or is it just there for
dramatic effect what happens if i have a
really loud fart
well as it turns out director john
krasinski did think about that last one
when working on the films he told his
actors and i quote just try to crop dust
what that tells me other than the fact
that a quiet place is a silent but
deadly world in more ways than one is
that there is a limit to how loud you
can be it's clear that the death angels
aren't bothered by certain sounds
otherwise they'd be drawn to the
family's nightly fire or the rustling of
the clothesline in the wind so what do
these monsters define as a tolerable
volume how loud can you afford to be in
a quiet place and still survive since
volume seems to be the key factor here
we're gonna need to look into measuring
sound in decibels so i grabbed my trusty
decibel meter from the crunchiest chip
episode of food theory and got to some
real life testing first was establishing
a baseline of what the aliens would and
wouldn't respond to in the film the
first kill in a quiet place happens when
a toy rocket ship noise blasts off so i
found a similar toy irl and measured it
with my meter to find that it rang in at
about 105 decibels a loud inorganic
noise like that is gonna be easily heard
by the aliens no surprises there however
we also have to factor in the variable
of distance as we all know being further
away from a noise makes it much quieter
so the alien wasn't responding to a
hundred plus decibel sound it was
actually able to hear something much
lower and immediately go on the attack
so how far away was the alien well it
took bow out in roughly 30 seconds
sprinting at what appears to be top
speed based on the car chase sequence at
the beginning of the second film we can
roughly estimate the distance that it
covered in that scene an alien catches
up to a 1975 oldsmobile delta 88 royale
after it's been floored for eight
seconds that's a car that can go zero to
60 in 11.9 seconds meaning that these
death angels can accelerate to a speed
of at least 40 miles per hour just as
quickly doing some quick calculations it
means that in order to hear the noise
bose rocket ship made and reach him in
time the creature was at most
1758 feet or 535.8 meters away now 1700
feet might seem like a long way off
however according to a noise attenuation
calculator even at that extreme distance
the noise would still clock in at 54
decibels that is data point number one
another attack happens in the first
movie when evelyn steps on a nail and
drops a glass picture frame here we
don't get a sense of the alien's
distance but real world testing shows
that glass breaking would clock in
around 90 decibels in other instances a
metal silo door opens which would be
around 100 db shotguns are fired which
is about 150 db and fireworks are used
as a distraction which makes a lot of
sense considering they're very loud 150
to 175 db in the sequel aliens are
alerted when people scream when they
rattle bottles and when they crash into
objects what do all of these noises have
in common two things the noises aren't
naturally occurring and they always have
sound levels above 50 decibels these two
factors seem to be the things that
always wind up alerting the aliens so
based on the first part of this analysis
i immediately have to call bs on the
corn that the abbott family has there
are several acres of perfectly planted
rose it's not like it's last year's crop
either because we see that harvest
slowly dying in the fields these stalks
are lush green they've clearly been
planted after the invasion i'm sorry but
tending to all this land is gonna make
over 60 decibels worth of noise you ever
crack corn off its stalk as a solid
alien whistle right there so now
equipped with a baseline of what it
takes to trigger an attack i then
started to test the things that we see
the survivors do in their day-to-day
lives i stuffed a backpack and walked on
all the surfaces that we see them cover
in the movies sand gravel grass concrete
i measured the noise of insects and
birds i clanged glass bottles against
each other i yelled as loudly as
possible and stood there like a creeper
to figure out the noise drop off of
neighborhood joggers
don't mind me i'm just recording how
loud you are for a youtube video by the
way would you help me find out how loud
getting a leg stuck in a bear trap would
be
it's for science after tabulating all
the results i'm kind of shocked to say
this but all the stuff we see him doing
in the movie yeah it's kind of a
necessity for survival in this world
walking on dried leaves is a literal
death sentence clocking in at minimum of
55 decibels stepping on a stick even
worse the resulting snap is upwards of
70 db and crunching along on gravel
isn't that far off either topping out at
45 decibels dangerously close to our 50
db limits walking on sand meanwhile
deadens the sound considerably lowering
the volume down to a much safer 35
decibels grass same deal so for as
ridiculously over the top as pouring out
pathways of sand might seem in the movie
turns out it's a great way to ensure the
safety of our survivors also a necessity
whispering a normal conversation tends
to happen in the 60 decibel range which
puts an immediate target on your back
but by softening it down to a whisper
which averages out at around 30 db
you're gonna be in the clear however
don't get too comfortable because our
acoustic surroundings are always
shifting and this is where advanced
survival techniques start coming into
play see during a quiet place evelyn
warns lee that sundown is rapidly
approaching
watching the movie i and i think the
rest of the audience assumed that this
warning was because it's easier to
travel during the day trails through the
woods are home to roots and uneven roads
that are begging for people to trip on
them at night and while that's certainly
a big threat one additional thing that
most people wouldn't think about here is
that sound travels further at night you
see under normal conditions the sun
heats the earth which means that during
the day warm air tends to be near the
surface and cooler air tends to be at
higher elevations sound waves travel
faster in warm air and tend to move
towards cooler temperatures it's a bit
of an oversimplification but roughly
that's how it works as such during the
day most sound refracts upwards into the
sky and quickly disappears amongst the
clouds however at night or when there's
dense cloud cover a temperature
inversion occurs cooler air stays near
the earth's surface and the warmer air
is found at higher elevations now when a
sound happens that sound wave is
refracted back down towards earth it
doesn't want to pass from cool air to
warm up the clouds the effect is that
sounds can now be heard much more
clearly over longer distances at night
so that's survival skills 301 do all
your business during the day also i know
you want to live close to water but it
might not be smart to live extremely
close to a lake during the nighttime
hours the colder water causes a natural
amplification that allows the sound
waves to travel further thus while it's
certainly smart to live near a water
source you just gotta make sure it's a
running water source don't just move
into the first lake house that you find
it's the equivalent of living next to an
organic megaphone this temperature
amplification effect also applies to
seasons of the year since the abbots
live in new york where there are some
incredibly cold harsh winters they have
to be extra careful during those months
according to david phillips senior
climatologist for environment canada
quote never tell a secret on a cold day
because you can hear people talking from
as far as 6 kilometers or 3.7 miles away
but this is all defensive let's talk
about going on the offense at the end of
the movie reagan discovers the monster's
weakness a specific pitch of feedback
coming from her cochlear implant but did
you notice that this feedback caused
uncontrollable muscle vibrations in the
death angel's body now it might just be
sensory overload short-circuiting the
death angel's brain function but a more
accurate analysis of what's going on
here appears to be tapping into the
monster's resonant frequency see pretty
much every material has a natural
frequency that it likes to vibrate at
when subjected to this frequency the
natural vibrations of the material are
at their most extreme in scientific
terms the amplitude of the vibration is
at its peak so if you can manage to hit
a material with its specific resonant
frequency loud and long enough it'll
vibrate so violently that it'll
eventually break this is how opera
singers are sometimes able to shatter
glassware now most living things are
made up of numerous soft organic
structures with varying resonant
frequencies which makes it hard to
weaponize sound but the death angels
just so have to be covered clawed a fang
in a singular dense armor-like material
and reagan's cochlear implant tapped
into exactly the right frequency so now
the question is what frequency are we
talking about listening to the scenes
where this technique is used in both
quiet place one and two you can tell
that the pitch actually shifts quite a
bit
[Music]
there's no one set frequency here
however after testing these using
various online frequency identification
tools the killer tone appears to be
somewhere between 1400
and 1900 hertz
did i pinpoint an exact pitch no but
have at least greatly narrowed the test
range for reference the tv audio test
sound
yeah that is a pure 1000 hertz tone a
typical smoke alarm meanwhile falls in
at three thousand four thousand hertz
range on youtube there are dozens of
standalone videos where pure tones of
these sonic ranges exist there's also a
handful of musical instruments that can
play in these frequencies high stringed
instruments like the violin and viola
high woodwinds like the flute and
piccolo even the piano in short you
don't need feedback from a cochlear
implant to survive you just need a solid
internet connection or you know some
basic music skills then by building up a
feedback loop of the armor's resonant
frequency the death angels will have
every inch of their exoskeletons buzzing
in multiple directions unable to keep
their plating aligned they open up
exposing the soft juicy weak point
inside which is the perfect opportunity
to strike so there you have it friends a
more scientific look at how to survive a
quiet place if you have to make noise
keep it under 50 decibels be extra
careful at night or on cold days stay
away from peaceful lakes that'll amplify
sounds and if you truly want to fight
back learn how to play an instrument
glad to see that my three years of
playing the viola badly throughout
middle school will finally pay off
but hey that's just a theory a film
theory and cuts
you